[SPEAKER_02]: Evening of the fourth o'clock time, Owen Black returns to the cabins, leaving the four crewmen on the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Somebody else had a bump with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: With Owen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, somebody else had hit the day to now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume he's in his own quarters.
[SPEAKER_02]: What he's saying is somebody else should go to sleep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, there's two quarters there, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's two rooms, two bunks, two whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if you guys don't need me, I can get to it, Bart.
[SPEAKER_00]: No singing of songs in the middle of the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you go into the cabin for eight hours to sleep, leaving the three of you on deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys want to have a discussion about anything or just go through the night?
[SPEAKER_03]: You got a handle on this, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: What you need to be doing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't want to have to think too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Leave that to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the goal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Feel free to share your thoughts.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll give my input but obviously you've got your
[SPEAKER_01]: I would just like to know anything and everything about what Owen's been up to lately and how he might be tied to the incident we had back at Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I do think it's pretty odd that he escaped the help of a couple of bugbears and then happens to get his ship back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just throwing that out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not saying I don't like the guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just saying it's pretty an odd deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And his close ties to Kane Tolley, I think it would be in best interest for me to try to get cozy with Kane Tolley and Owen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anyone that's going to earn his trust, I'm the last one on that list.
[SPEAKER_03]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think he's too far involved in it, but he might know enough.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think he's that involved, I think he's just more of an helpful idiot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen will go where the money is.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Owen has ears like us too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it would be good to pry his mind as much as we could.
[SPEAKER_01]: He seems to take a liking to Folsom, so maybe when he's up we can try to see if he can work a name as Bard Charm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe hopefully write a song to get Owen a little more excited.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep Owen happy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep them sharp eyes on that horizon out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Leave the digging to me, but if he says anything, please let me know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, and also let Folsum know.
[SPEAKER_03]: He might throw a couple jabs at one of us in the song.
[SPEAKER_03]: Might really tie Owen in even better with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anything to boost Evan's ego, I think, is good.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the big thing is that these supplies are going to help the city of Monmurg release some of the tensions.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the important part.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it would seem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: You never know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good man.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to keep my eyes on the sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to keep sailing forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Around midnight, you turn the ship into the space between the islands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Into the wind?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is the wind still coming north?
[SPEAKER_02]: The wind's still going north.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you begin to pick up speed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now this gap is probably about, I would say, between three and five miles as you go through it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to stay close to the shoreline or do you want to go just down the middle?
[SPEAKER_02]: There are watchtowers and light towers on both sides.
[SPEAKER_03]: Obviously you would know better than the rest of us, but is this friendly?
[SPEAKER_03]: This is friendly water.
[SPEAKER_03]: These are friendly waters.
[SPEAKER_03]: This isn't where we've got to be.
[SPEAKER_03]: You would know where you would have to be when we come around here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We've got to have peeled eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: A Commodore's patrol may try to intercept you.
[SPEAKER_02]: They do patrol these waters, but it's very rare, and if you know the signals, they won't mess with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: What would I know is more, at this time of day, this area, are ships going to be usually, I'd assume, probably closer to the shoreline versus out in the middle?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_02]: Normally the big ships go in the middle.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to say go to the middle, but I am going to lean closer to this.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm not dead in the middle.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I need to, I can go to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hug this as we go around?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hug it, but not right upon it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can see it from a distance.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the night goes on, and at four in the morning,
[SPEAKER_02]: You're kind of coming out of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to continue or do you want to wake up on black or do you want to wait until morning comes?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to slow down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the wind still with us?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Speed's our friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do want to check the waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to check the area again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there still sahagin a ton floating by us, or is that kind of washed out?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, sahagin washed out around here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ah shit, I should have slept a few hours before this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I'm pretty much laying on the deck anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kind of in and out.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going to here, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, we're going over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said it's been, how long has Ellen been asleep for?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he went to bed at sundown around eight o'clock, seven o'clock, so he's been asleep maybe eight hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to go wake Owen and Folsom up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to try to get rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I go down and go to wake them up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go down.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll stay up a bit and then leave me when you get enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so I'll head down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I go to wake.
[SPEAKER_00]: I knock on his quarters first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I stay up on the deck with...
[SPEAKER_03]: I want you up there with me until the other two come up.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, shit, for that matter I'll go get them up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, you're at the helm.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll go do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to wake Folsom?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please wake Folsom, send him up first, and then I will... We'll have Folsom wake him up, Owen up.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to talk to Folsom before.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll send Folsom up and then he can come down and wake him up.
[SPEAKER_03]: That way he's getting buddy-buddy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep, yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I go, Gouge wakes you up at like four in the morning.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've had your aid, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go up and talk to Merrick.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's going to have you come back down and get Owen.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to op-munk with you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Once you're up there with Owen, send Ty down.
[SPEAKER_00]: The cabin's right next to each other.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're very close to each other.
[SPEAKER_00]: I tiptoe up to the deck and climb here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I see Merrick on the deck, chilling?
[SPEAKER_02]: You see Merrick at the wheel, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go up next.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need it?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to have Owen take the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need you up here with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need you to work on a song about Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Funny you mention that.
[SPEAKER_00]: As soon as I went to bed, I started writing a song.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need you, Folsom, to work your charm.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want you to be his best friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Information, buddy-buddy, make this an unforbidable trip for him where he wants to go with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Trips galore.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gonna be heartbreaking when he has to see you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he's not gonna want to leave my son.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I need to rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you notice anything out here, I know you're probably not the wisest when it comes to this scene, but if you notice anything that would give you a stir, you need to wake me up immediately.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I was a part of you, but thank you for a reason.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's a problem, wait, it's all up.
[SPEAKER_00]: YouTube growth done?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm out.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a fucking dick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Give me about...
[SPEAKER_03]: Give me about four hours and then I'll swap with Ty.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so I'm standing on deck.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, you stand on deck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need about four because I've just been...
[SPEAKER_00]: But he's headed down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rested in and out anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so Merrick goes down and you go and wake up, Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure you cuddle in the right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bump there, cutie.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he basically comes up to the deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tyrus is staying up in front of the four hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: You go down into the cabin and go to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you and Owen, four in the morning, Tyrus on deck, sailing down the sea.